starts really great cool well yeah thank
you for having me my name is Tom Weldon
I'm here from decision lab and they're
going to talk on - giving interactive
data visualization web applications
without JavaScript and so an alternative
title for this talk and would be what
you can can't should and probably
shouldn't do with plotly - and so today
I'm going to cover a bit about why you
might want to use that crucially and
give a basic introduction to it how it
works and the kind of things that you
can actually do with - and then I want
to kind of discuss what we've learned
from using - across various different
teams that decisions lab and and then at
the end please the over the beers and
through the fire alarm come and approach
me and we'll go out the building
evacuate and carry on talking about -
somehow and so I want to give a very
brief disclaimer day before I carry on
and so I'm not really a - expert or I'm
not an author on this project and yes I
got a couple of pull requests that I
want to do at some point but and you
know I'm not a key contributor or
anything this talk really is about using
- at work it's not an advert for - as a
framework or - is a a tool by plot B and
I do want to apologize as well if anyone
from plotly ends up seeing this and
saying no that's terrible that's wrong
that's not fair and then please get in
touch and maybe I'll reply to email
maybe not say okay so if I'm not a -
expert and you know I'm not an author or
so on why am I here and you know why
have I come to Prague to talk about that
and and more to the point as well I'm a
full-stack developer I'm not just an a
Python developer I'm working Python
various databases through rust and
JavaScript like CSS I'm a full stack
developer so it's a bit weird really to
be using Python to be writing JavaScript
and so why am i doing that and well the
answer is that as I say I worked for
decision lab and we're a mathematical
modeling consultancy based in central
London and actually on that point as
well
if you're following all the latest
debacle and excrements storm that was
going on in my country at the moment but
I really am very sorry about that
and I have no idea what's going on there
either
actually having been traveling through
Europe for the last month or so it's
kind of sad to you and I think I'm going
back there on Friday and still I think
that and what we have across Europe
actually with the kind of the Python
community pie data's and open-source
software generally is really very
special and I really want to do kind of
and you know celebrate everyone that
comes to events like this and wherever
you come from or wherever your goatee is
it really is quite special the community
that we have and so moving on decision
lab and we have expertise across various
different domains machine learning
optimization simulation and some that
main things that we do we work in
Defense Intelligence engineering various
other kind of public bodies we've worked
for the Food Standards Agency to predict
how good a restaurant will be on a
machine learning model we lose and weird
and wacky projects and that's because we
like interesting and unusual problems
more than anything else rather than
doing the same thing over and over again
and crucially we don't just write
reports like a standard and consultancy
we build tools that clients can use on
their data and that might be a very
simple proof of concept tool for just
one you know one small project but then
our aim is always that that will lead to
something bigger and something you know
a phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 and we start
to build up big up for the bigger
products and so it's an example of some
other and restaurants aside example of
some other projects we've done we've
recently done a project using machine
learning to detect illegal gold mining
in Columbia and built a tool that was
used by the Colombian government to um
go and see whether or not deforestation
is related to your legal gold mining or
if it's for some other reason and we're
currently working to deploy and machine
learning or neural network based
predictive maintenance model aboard a
type 45 destroyer for the Royal Navy say
we're we're not deploying to a yes we're
at the point was year we were deplane to
the bloody ship that and this really
does complicate it sometimes and but
these are kind of the examples of some
of the recent projects we've done
and we'll come back to the gold mining
project and briefly a little bit later
and but this is actually something that
I was talking about over a break as well
actually one thing that we've noticed at
decision lab or that I certainly noticed
when I'd kind of reflect on my new the
culture of programming and the company
is that there are really sort of two
cultures of Python here and unless you
haven't guessed or idea I really quite
like a Modi say I've represented them
here with their sort of the and
technically builder sort of emoji and
the the scientist emoji so you kind of
got these data scientists and software
engineers and if you're familiar with
and some work in the humanities by CP
snow there's this very famous essay in
the 1950s and way to discuss the the two
cultures of academia and this idea that
you on the one hand you've got the arts
and then on the other hand you've got
the sciences and there's this kind of
gulf of mutual incomprehension between
the two and I'm not saying it's that bad
don't think it's that bad at all but
there is definitely and you know you can
classify people into potentially into
two broad groups as either maybe a
software engineer maybe you're more
concerned about the web django flash
sequel alchemy that kind of thing and or
perhaps you're a data scientist where
you're more thinking about all this
neural network
you know this machine learning model and
panders that sort of thing and and and
in fact it's reflected in our
communities as well we have you know PI
cons and PI data's and what's those
things two things come together in
collaboration is key
in the workplace when you're working on
a deadline on a project often that kind
of collaboration can be quite costly if
you're having to sort of have teams
mixed together to produce basic proof of
concept things and so in my role I'm in
charge of our production teams I take
things from clever data scientists and
turn them into stable products and you
know I really want to minimize the new
technologies that a data scientist or a
consultant has to learn in order to be
able to start doing something really
quickly and making something useful
impressive for a client and and so I
really want the data scientist here to
take the lead on maybe prototyping say
like a proof-of-concept dashboard or
something for a client that they can do
very very quickly that's not going to go
into full-scale production with
thousands and thousands of users but is
going to be something that maybe in a
week or twos time we can come back to a
client and say hey we've got this thing
for you how do you all consider using it
and so that's how we came across - and
and I'm really not making this up
actually and it's in too good to be true
to not include it but about an hour ago
I got a message on our company slack
from one of my colleague of mine who's
joined very very recently as you're
saying that I'll she's wants to build a
really simple tool that some of our
engineering clients can use to produce a
curve in response to a couple of numbers
they used to do it in Excel but didn't
really work properly good we've done
something similar at university with our
shiny but we're not really sure how to
do that and no one really in the company
uses our anymore what can we do with
there and what could we use to do this
and so I introduced her to our kind of
company and doksan - so that really was
like about 45 minutes of an hour ago
that I got this message so it seemed
very very apt and so - is an open source
project there are some paid consultancy
options as well and I think in June this
year it hit version one so it's quite a
young project but it's been around for a
little while and but you know it does it
does change quite rapidly and it's kind
of tagline or it's sort of unique
styling point is that you can build
interactive websites without using
JavaScript and some of you might think
that's a good thing do you think that's
a good thing
pie data yeah
whereas obviously if you're maybe a
suffer engineer you think oh gosh what's
what's going to happen here and but so
for the rest of this talk I want to give
sort of a brief overview of how data
works I want to kind of give some
examples of the sort of things that you
can do with - very quickly discuss some
potential good practices so to speak on
- as you start to build larger
applications
and then give a brief opinion on sort of
when to stop using - and to start
building a more involved or proper web
application and there are several code
examples in this talk and I'll put this
link up several times in these slides
and if you go to that link there on my
github and you can get all of these code
examples and there's a handy little
docker compose as well that you can just
run and then the links and the readme of
that that github repository will start
to magically work if you run it on your
laptop um okay so first things first
install bash obviously using pip and
let's build a hello world application so
here we've got the code example and
sorry I can't really maneuver to do this
but you can see we're doing a couple of
things here first things first we import
- and - libraries there or - packages
sorry
and I'll come to in a minute or T we
create an app here just like you might
create a flask application or something
and actually under the hood - is
building a flask application for you
when you do that and we define this
layout here and here we're just doing a
very simple one we've got a division tag
with a heading tag in the middle of it
and then you can see at the end we just
run our application and so unfortunately
is no real slick way to do this with
Google slides so if you give me a moment
you can see here this is running on my
laptop now using that docker image and
so now I've just created a very very
hello world website using nothing but
Python and it's running on my laptop
locally you can see how I've cheated as
well because I put a little decision lab
Logan up at the top here that's just
using a stylesheet and that - we'll look
for automatically so there's nothing
nothing special about that okay and so
if we look at what what's going on here
and those two packages that we imported
and important the first one was
something called - HTML components and
these are just wrappers so around
reactive components so it creates bits
of the webpage or bits of the the HTML
layout in the page called - components
they wrap react components and
active components just wrap HTML tags so
it's basically a way of defining an HTML
tag layout and using nothing but Python
and then this second library here - and
that manages the relationships between
these components and it also serves
their application using flask so moving
on and as I said the title of this talk
is all about building an interactive web
page and so far all we've done is
display hello Prague with an emoji and
that's not going to impress your clients
as much as perhaps an interactive emoji
based website would do so I'm going to
suggest that net the next thing we do is
build a sort of hello anyone kind of
application using these beautiful F
strings here is everyone does everyone
use these or the people still using like
percent it who's using percent symbols
in percent symbols I really do okay
great good audience okay so we're gonna
build an application that's basically
just gonna say hello anyone but before
we start doing that in - let's think
about how that would work in JavaScript
and and so first things first we're
going to have to define our HTML layout
and here we've got three Dom nodes and
when I say Dom nodes as well I'm not
being vain here because my name's Dom I
document object model I did actually
look up whether or not because my name
means are often in European languages
like Russian pigs well it means a house
and so I wondered if that was that was
the case in Czech but apparently it's
like doom or something the Middle's
Miller character in the middle in Dutch
it means stupid so you know and still
being better than the ordinary
and okay so I've got at least three
three Dom nodes here and that we're
defining one of them is a paragraph node
you can see here and inside that
paragraph node we've got this span and
we're giving that span an ID which is
denoted with that hashtag there and
we've got this input as well which is a
child sorry which is a sibling of the
paragraph node and that's got an ID as
well so we now need to write a
JavaScript program it's going to take
the value from inside of our input
this input node and put it up set it as
the value inside of that spam mode but
the thing it crucially also has to do is
carry on monitoring that for any changes
because if it happens just once and say
in response to a single key press it's
not going to happen for all the
subsequent key presses because this is a
website things can change it's it's
stateful you know it's not just
something that happens once and so in
ordinary front-end web development we
would use JavaScript to manipulate our
Dom I'm very manipulable apparently and
that javascript essentially has access
to the document object model and can
change the web the web page and then we
use react as a declarative system to be
able to say rather than having to write
I forgot a complex web application just
to constantly you know monitor this
input tag and then see if we need to
change anything we just declare in react
how we want our webpage to behave and
then react sorts the rest of it out for
us
and so the precise syntax here isn't
important this is JavaScript don't boo
me but here we know it's an final
application is going to look something a
bit like this this is a JavaScript
function it's going to live inside of
our browser and it's just going to take
the value from our input and it's going
to return it inside of this this span
tag so this is react code or JSX
up here okay meanwhile say yeah so in
react our JavaScript function which
lives in the browser defines the
behavior that we want to implement
meanwhile though - it things a little
bit more complex and so interactions are
handled by these callbacks which are
functions that are on the server that
are called whenever their inputs change
and so if we give an example here you
can see how I've specified this this
layout and you know we've got the
division tag like we had before and I
put this heading tag up here with an
input as well so this is going to take
take some text my user and then I've
specified this function below that here
which is a callback and we're telling -
that basically whenever this
you hear so the value inside of our
input changes using this decorator I
want you to run this function which is
just going to interpolate that string
and say hello whoever and then I want
you to specify as the value inside of
this heading today we're just saying
whenever this input changes run my
function and then set it as the output
inside of this spam here and so to give
you an example of what that would look
like
no no G this time on this one I'm afraid
and so here we have this hello
prog you can see missus running on my my
laptop now I've just refreshed and so I
could do have a prior to Medicare do
have a high data and you can see now
we've got a fully interactive web page
here and it's gonna change as we know we
can write anything in here you can put
whatever we want and we haven't had to
write a single line of JavaScript so far
and you know this is a very basic
example and but with that very basic
example you can start to slot things
together and to really make much more
complicated web applications with your
data and/or your sort of clients the
only issue is day that these callbacks
now are Python functions and Python
lives on and they're called whenever the
inputs change but Python sort of lives
on the server and so that means that
every change now on our website requires
some call to go from our client to our
server and and then come back again to
say how that webpage should be changed
that's five minutes on my laptop running
on docker locally because if I had
network issues with inside my own laptop
docker then I think something would be
very very wrong but if it's happening
say on the internet that can get a bit
slower and it can cause some performance
loss however that performance loss isn't
really a big deal and you know it might
be slightly larger than your average web
page it's not going to be a slick is
Airbnb or Facebook or something like
that and but you know the aim of a -
website really is to allow my data
scientist building out really really
quickly using technologies that they're
familiar with broadly and to make
something that will go into a proof of
concept or possibly like a very early
it's not to produce a sort of full you
know it's not rival Amazon or something
like that it's just to create a little
you know data-driven application and so
if we take it a bit further and ask what
can you do with - as a whole
as the name implies it's really very
much focused towards building dashboards
but that being said you can also add
quite a lot of you know interactive or
what I call transactional functionality
quite easily as well which we'll show in
a moment or so and so some of the other
examples on here as you say they're all
in this this github repository and but
the three examples I'm going to show now
are listing a dataset that means this
instance says everyone come across the
Titanic data set yeah nice simple data
set to start with and yeah say I just
lifted passengers that you can't display
we're gonna build a graph based on that
that Titanic data set and then I'm gonna
show you finally a classic to-do
application which is always like a you
know web development - a tutorial
starter application and you can do very
simply in - as well so very speedily
we'll go through these now as they're
displaying the Titanic passengers and
here we've got a component for that in -
and so here you can see there's this -
data table which you can use so here
i've just given it a particular ID of my
table i've specified the columns as
being the columns that are in my data
frame currently and you can see I've
actually left the data here blank and
that's because I'm going to specify the
data according to the value of this
drop-down box here which I've created
and so the drop-down box is going to
allow user to filter the passengers
based on their sex so you actually need
to show all of the passengers just the
man or just the women and so the way
that I take doing that it's by having
this callback function and so you can
see again here I've specified inside of
this decorator basically whenever my
drop-down value changes I want you to
run this function and change the output
and I've just got a really dead simple
filter operation there on this panda's
data frame so without further ado if we
show an example of that working
so here you can see I'll just refresh so
you can get the full experience and so
here you can see at this titanic dataset
being displayed and I've got all of the
passengers being displayed at the moment
and they're quite you know visually
decent sort of table this is something
you could use for and lots of different
client use cases and I said ah now I
want to show you just the two Jen's
innocent model but you know just just
the women and then I said now I wanted
to show you just the men you can see it
alters that again and I'll go back to
you so you can see now that again just
in a really simple few lines of Python
we've created a fully interactive sort
of you know way of displaying the
contents of a data frame and you know if
you were to link that together say with
an input or a slider or some other kind
of you know controlling - and there are
plenty inside of the standard - library
it's not hard to see how actually you
could go to creating quite an advanced
dashboard that allows you to do quite a
bit of stuff without too much mental
overhead and also just as a little
example of another thing here and that
comes with some really great debugging
tools that you can use say for example
down here in this debug mode if I want
to visualize what's happening on my on
my webpage I've got this thing called a
callback graph and it's all visualized
for me in a little debugging tool here
the fact that I've got my eyesight isn't
quite good enough to read this now but
you can see here that I've got and these
three nodes and some relationships
between them and so when something
doesn't work or you're not quite sure
what's happening you have a whole suite
of tools down the bottom right-hand side
of your browser to be able to debug this
on the fly okay cool so that's our first
example then our second example here and
displaying a graph I mentioned so
obviously plotly and they have a big
plotting library and they're very you
know well named for their own
visualizations and this is actually one
line of Python here I realized and I've
always wanted to do a lightning talk
about exactly what you can do in one
line
and sometimes but and because it's
formatted with black hopefully you'll
forgive me and you can see here we've
defined another layout and this time
I've literally just got a heading with a
graph inside of it and inside of that
graph I just labeled my my series and my
data and they're sort of the annotations
for it and I've got this other
fantastically convoluted one-line
function that I wrote as well which
basically takes a data frame series or a
series in in pandas and then we'll count
return return to tuples of a return a
list of two tuples that tell you the
first letter of the alphabet er at the
alphabet and then the number of people
in this data set that have that that
have a name have a first name that
begins with that letter so basically I'm
figuring out how many people are it have
the first name begin with ABCDEF cetera
and so then you can see that's that part
and then I've just fed that data into it
as well so now if we look at what that
actually looks like in - you can see
here and that we've got 26 columns here
on our histogram and apparently the most
common letter by looks of this was J jr.
is that I someone got better eyesight
can they J okay good stuff so you don't
wanna be doing this don't have a name J
cool
so finally moving on as I said you can
actually also build rather than just
displaying data inside of your your -
application you can actually start to
change things in your data as well and
so I call these that transactional tools
and so the classic one here is building
a really basic to do application and I
get to do this where you just put what
tasks you have on and so on and so here
again I've defined a layout and this
time I've got my heading at the top I've
got an unordered list or a ul there it's
going to display all of my tasks and
it's handled by that lists tasks
function I've got my input as well it's
going to take the name of a task
and then this button so that when you
click the button it takes whatever is in
the input and then adds it to the task
list and then that's going to display
just play your new task and you can see
here that is this I haven't used the
database here but for the sake of
simplicity by just created am a global
variable here that is a dictionary that
has a list inside of it obviously you
could replace that with something like
MongoDB if you really hated yourself
before you could replace it with like a
sequel database if you had some
self-esteem and being on Sarah Monday
there and here so you can see you've got
this function to list our tasks and then
we have this callback here to add a task
into our and into our list and as you
can see here we're going to say
basically run this function every single
time that this button is clicked and
then just return a return a list of all
of these different tasks and it's going
to be put inside of our and inside of
our unordered list on our layout and say
there's an example here so you could say
I want to write some tools here I'll
zoom in a bit here so you can see this
you could do something like okay and now
obviously because I've stood this in my
laptop so the global names based all my
other global variable here when i
refresh this page boom it's still that
and so obviously you could put that in a
in a database and I've got nothing
against [ __ ] really I just don't like
it
and and you know you could you could
actually start to change your dataset as
well as just displaying it and so I can
give you an example of when we've done
exactly that actually decision I have in
the moment you say it's call back here
finally it's like you can also build
your own - components and if you're
competent with JavaScript and you want
to sort of build something it doesn't
exist yet that's totally cool you can do
it I would say that the the - API
actually inside of JavaScript is
slightly limited and it does limit some
of the things you can do especially with
access to you and some more advanced
tools like Redux and again that's that
you know it's a cost benefit isn't it
and the important thing is that you can
go very far with - and say for example
before when I mentioned that project
about illegal gold mining in the
Amazonian rainforest and that was built
by two data scientists using - and we
developed a tool here that and uses
human-in-the-loop machine learning so
here we display using this this map
component that we built a wrapper around
leaflet and so here you can see all of
the different areas of deforestation
that we think might be down to illegal
gold mining and then the users in the
Colombian government are actually able
to say is this correct or is it not
correct now you can see here this this
isn't the it's actually a slightly
earlier version of it as well it's not
the slickest web application you ever
seen and but it wasn't intended to be
really it was built by - you know data
scientist Mart's they were also
developing the model at the same time
and it resulted in a really useful sort
of proof of concept and demonstrator for
future projects that we can sort of use
and build off of that
this wasn't a project that was built by
loads of complex software engineering
stuff from putting loads of resource of
software engineers onto the project this
was all done by data scientists who knew
about what they were doing and so
inevitably if you start building larger
- applications and the crucial thing
here - so there's lots of different tips
that I'd love to talk about more in
depth but do organize your code
especially things like splitting up your
callbacks and your layouts and running
your application using a main rather
than just a random script and an
abstract you've have logical business
stuff or a business logic from from your
callbacks as well I'd say it's like a
standard layout that we might use here
but can I skip over at the time being
one thing a decision that we are doing
at the moment is trying to work towards
more of a - framework
and said we're running this is an open
source project that's what a nascent
open source project at the moment so we
want to start to take care of things
like routing and navigation and provide
a really sort of simple set of tools so
that if you want to build a larger data
application rather than reinventing the
wheel all the time you can use an open
source project say this is something you
might be interested in please do get in
touch and that finally kind of comes to
the point when should you stop using -
and start to build like in the inverted
quotes like a proper web application
well my answer to that is that - is
great for two reasons you have really
rapid UI development by non-specialists
you know data scientists can build their
own tools and go very very far very very
fast without too much complex or a team
of specialists sort of development
knowledge it's really informed
development as well because these data
scientists are the people that are
building the application know exactly
what their problem is and you know what
how this relates to their client and the
user and so on and they can really fit
build an application that fits their
analysis that being said some of the
downsides are that it's really rapid UI
development by non-specialists so know
if you're going to be building a web
application and it's going to go into
production eventually maybe you should
start getting some technical you know
front-end developers on board fairly
quickly because you're going to need
them eventually you might be creating
technical debt you want to start
investing time in the front-end early on
rather than catching up later
and likewise about that informed UI
development they've scientists brilliant
people but they're not necessarily UX
consultants or designers or people who
are you know they they perhaps
understand their their problem but
that's not necessarily the way to build
the best application in the world and so
you know I think you need to use a
researcher and you know if this is going
to be a bigger project at what point you
start to get you know user researchers
and user active than UX consultants
involved so finally - is a great tool
for facilitating rapid UI development of
data driven interfaces and dashboards if
you invest a bit of time and effort into
it you can go very very far especially
if you organize your code inside of a -
application and eventually front-end
developers are basically going to keep
their jobs so
make of that what you will thank you
cool and that please do you get in fact
about when should you stop using - to
start building a proper website there's
a question related that when is it time
to studying visualization in Jupiter and
start doing them in - well I try and as
a habit actually we know off do you buy
two notebooks as quickly as I can
mostly because I find my opinion of GPI
two notebooks is sometimes that it you
write lots of pricing code and it's
staged just adjacent object with lots of
states and stuff inside of it and that's
great but it's really if you know you
want to edit it in jupyter and run us a
little bit is it that hard to then copy
it over into something out sort of
extract it from there and so I would say
sooner rather than later but I have
other data scientist colleagues that I
respect very much that absolutely adore
G Python notebooks and thing that I'm
talking nonsense so I think that's a
real open-ended question and I'd say if
you want your carry to ever be used by
people who aren't bigger scientists
using G pi2 notebooks then start
thinking about how you can make your
code more accessible in that often it's
just in a Unicode file that you can
share with people and they can do
whatever they want yeah well so there
are lots of alternatives for especially
if you want to do just visualization and
so the classic ones are things like
bouquet and I've got a new one I came up
with the other day that has it lead me
sorry and damn now I'll remember the
name and then tweeter doesn't think and
but I think that the thing that makes -
sort of stand apart is that ability to
do transactional stuff so rather than
just displaying your data or you know
creating something that is explicitly a
dashboard if you actually want to create
something that's an application there's
also a dashboard and could actually go a
little bit further than you know just
visualization to actually
changing things on your server and
providing other functionality - allows
you to do that whereas I'm not aware
that or not sure there's some things
like bouquet and this other thing that
I've just gone out of my head I'm afraid
and necessarily allow you to do in the
same way no not really so - to create a
- component you have to create a react
component so if you've got a react
component that you like then you can
wrap that to be able to use it in - and
but if there's a - component you really
like and think oh I'd love to use that
in my react application if you go and
look on github to find out where the
source code of that application is then
it'll be logically separated and you'll
be able to find it somewhere so they're
all developed by the ones out of the box
are developed by plotly um but for
example if you had if you want to create
your own
- component and you could take any old
react component and then wrap that in -
which is what we've done for react
leaflet and which I wouldn't say it's a
most stable thing in the world because
react leaflet and react don't always
play very nicely together but for
example we've done that for leaflet maps
quite recently
yeah say deployment at mine we just you
entirely through docker and because it
makes make sense it's very very
straightforward and is sometimes a
slight pain and especially if you have
to deploy in a client machine and it's
like that we only use Windows 7 or other
things like that and you have to find
alternatives to it and I got approached
by someone very recently actually about
starting a project to simplify some of
this and so that you can literally just
you know maybe run a command that allows
you to and containerize your your -
application very quickly and
straightforwardly rather than having to
play around with your own custom docker
so if that's something you're interested
in maybe drop me online or something you
can we can talk about it and yeah I'm
also quite keen to figure out if I could
make - serverless
and that that's probably my Christmas
project and no sir my what was one of
the reasons why I'm I know mostly about
- ouch is because I also the data
science team said oh this is like the
best solution for us at the moment and I
people have mentioned holidays to me
I've seen some things from it and I
don't know enough to be able to give it
kind of a coherent
no not yet so I've heard a lot of people
say good things about Celia and it's one
of those languages that seems to have
like a very very enthusiastic cult
following and moment I'm in the rust
camp in that I haven't I haven't tried
the Julia Campea and it's certainly
something that I'd love to see them to
explore in the future but and like I
can't say I've used am afraid minutes
until then feel free to finish all the
drinks and everything I have got any
questions for any of us than three two
approaches we're gonna organize our next
Meetup probably sometime early next year
if again if you've got any suggestions
for topics I think that you'd be
interested in anything you want to
present please do tell us we always love
to hear more about topics that we don't
know much about like - or the automotive
industry thank you Amy
[Applause]